[Music]
and if we didn't get a chance to talk
about this yesterday I'm just curious
what you did for Father's Day it's way
too late to be talking about that
we'll take a break with you oh well my
kids say yeah we had you know we had
brunch and then my kids gave me this
really awesome mug says world's best dad
isn't that nice
I'm a dope did the guy that taunts me
eating french fries ah see world's best
dad yeah I mean I can see it I can see
the sticker I know I know
I'm a little slow so this made me really
happy
let me just say wasn't in that knife
yeah isn't that nice well would be nice
except check this out my kids also got
me a world's best dad mug mug mug how
did this happen yeah what the hell
happened we can't both be the world's
best dad only one of us can be the
world's best well how the hell do we
settle this
well from sunny Burbank California time
to find out who is the world's
[Applause]
let's meet our contestants everybody
here's ND father of two his hobbies
include napping and sound financial
advice for you to talk to me like that
and this is coated also a father of two
his hobbies are do-it-yourself home
theater wiring and texting memes of Tom
Brady our first category is get in the
car the question is what time do you
need to leave for the airport if your
flight is at 5:30 p.m. 1:30 a.m. the day
before that's correct
oh man next category my house my rules
why did it the kids turn off the lights
they think I'm made of money
that is correct next category are we
there yet
the question is are we lost I'm taking
the shortcut I'm taking a short walk
this category is called Paula tricks
it's a pun here's the question what is
your political leanings
I haven't voted since Carter no I'm
sorry the correct answer is they're all
nuts next category the talk
the question is dad what's but stuff no
I'm sorry that's not right okay so I'm
sorry the correct answer is go ask your
mother's yeah mom mom doesn't know trust
me
I've tried to show her let's explore
that Andy could you elaborate I've sent
her email my password
no go Skee exit only next category my
last nerve here's a question where the
hell are my goddamn keys who took them
they were just here did you find your
keys yes so where were they in my pocket
that's correct
[Applause]
Conan is in the lead as we enter the
final round even though there's no
stores of anyway there's the question
boo where are your kids right now Andy
you go first one is watching TV and the
others at art class that's correct
Conan at school oh no I'm sorry school
is out for the summer actually I'll
steal this one actually that's not part
of the game but go ahead
one of Conan's kids is in the pool
unsupervised and the other is looking at
his dad's unpassed word protected porn
field laptop that's correct
how did you know that Andy they posted
it on snapchat and it's official you are
the world's best dad and yeah here you
go thank you
I don't get to keep my mug well you can
but just know that it is meaningless now
this has been
[Applause]
Kuki sorry little sloppy though it's
worth the scrap it's the world ready for
a game show parity
[Music]
you